extreme pro-abortion positions like the  laws or distally recently passed in the  state of New York had begun to provoke  an equally extreme pro-life reaction in  states like Georgia and this is leading  to a public conversation about the  fundamental moral questions of the issue  of abortion mainly do there have to be  any reasons given for abortion that is  to say is abortion at a moral question  and the justifications that are given  for difficult late term pregnancy  terminations do are those going to  extend back to the earliest abortions  which are the vast majority of abortions  that are performed in America